this is our second installment of the
startup checklist in the first
installment
we asked questions around your
suitability to be a founder right like
the inherent
uh qualities and skills you have so we
said hey listen are you solving a
problem that has personal relevance
can you yourself build a great product
or question three can you recruit elite
talent to join your team four do you
understand your ideal customer uh
profile and who your ideal customer is
who you're selling to
we asked how much personal runway do you
have how much are you willing to
sacrifice or said another way are you
resilient
do you have a bias towards action and we
unpacked why that's important
do you need a boss do you need somebody
to be monitoring your work we asked that
question in the first
10 questions in our checklist do you
make excuses
and do you wait for permission to do
things and uh can you build a startup
flywheel and do you even know what one
of those are so that was our first
installment today we're going to cover
business models for your startup it's
critically important for you to
understand your business model because
what we're doing here in silicon valley
and in the venture capital space is
we're giving you milestone based funding
you hit a milestone we give you money
you hit the next milestone we give you
more money that's typically how this
goes and you have to build your
credibility and you have to build your
performance over time
to get more money to fuel your vision if
you can't hit the milestones you really
are unlikely to clear market with
venture capitalists so it's one of the
beautiful things uh and also one of the
brutal things in fact it's brutal if i
were to pick a word it's beautifully
brutal
in that you perform or you're out of the
league it's basically that simple if
you're in the nba there's a certain
number of slots you're in competition to
be on your team and to make the 15 on
your individual team if your free throw
shooting sucks
if you don't work hard in practice
you're just not going to get a seat
right
on the bench or even in the starting
lineup same thing with startups so
let's get into it right now
first question i want to ask you so this
is our 11th overall question in the in
the startup checklist so i'll refer to
it as uh question number 11
and you can go to this week in
startups.com
checklist and you'll see this whole
checklist we're gonna put it uh into a
notion page uh our favorite wiki and
you'll be able to go down there and see
my notes and it's live right now you can
go check it out and uh we're hoping that
this becomes a living breathing document
maybe you remix it maybe you take some
of the questions i'm asking here link
back to it give a credit and you know
take one of my points and and debate it
maybe you write a full blog post out of
it maybe you do a clubhouse or twitter
spaces or call in you know room about uh
some questions on this checklist or you
adapt it otherwise for yourself and
build upon it
so founders
know what the important questions are to
ask themselves so question 11 pick a
business model that easily aligns with
your product or service and customers so
what do we mean by this there are many
business models uh in the world
in venture businesses uh there are a few
that scale and get the returns venture
capitalists and their limited partners
the people who they're investing money
from
uh on behalf of uh like and so
if you look at all the great companies
in silicon valley in the technology
space they basically knew how they were
going to make money
from day one now sometimes they waited
till day
500 to turn on that business model i.e
an advertising startup like google uh
might
spend a year or two just perfecting the
search engine instagram might spend a
year or two just perfecting their uh
image-based social network and then when
they hit some level of scale they turn
on advertising and that's one of the
business models advertising advertising
business models are great but they are
not the only one there are subscriptions
right you can subscribe to a product or
service be it com.com for meditation as
a consumer or be it slack or notion for
your enterprise so the business model
needs to match the type of product or
service you're offering and it needs to
match and be effortless for your
customers now if you're providing a free
service that people are unwilling to pay
for let's say social media is not
something people are willing to pay for
um because there's so many choices of
free products out there well you know
getting them to pay for it might be hard
uh previously people thought that
getting people to pay for content as
consumers would be hard because oh
netflix is only 12. and look at how much
you get from that why would anybody pay
for a subset of that meditation or
subset of that dance videos or a subset
of that exercise videos you get the idea
well if they're really world-class and
better than what's out there then people
will pay for it and we've seen that
through a lot of the investments we've
made fitpod uh and calm come to mind
steezy in other ones so imagine if you
pick the wrong business model right uh
let's say your uber and instead of
charging people a percentage of the ride
you said you know it's 25 a month to be
part of the uber network and
then uh we take no percentage of
your rides right the rides are just
between you and the driver it's a
membership club well people did try that
actually uh there were people who had uh
concepts around that where people would
either donate like sidecar or maybe
there would be a monthly fee to be part
of this marketplace but that would have
added a ton of friction
what people wanted was just
obscurify or just abstract
what i'm paying to uber for the service
and just make it easy i don't want to
pay a monthly fee of course if you look
at a company like costco you know costco
exists because they have a very
compelling concept you buy in bulk
other services don't have buy in bulk
they sell you things as you want them
you know you can buy one croissant or 10
but you're not forced to buy 24 like you
are at costco so different business
models will work um but you want to make
sure that
the business model is elegant and simple
elegantly simple is what we're looking
for here we give you a meditation app
you pay us we give you software you pay
us
um we're a marketplace if you get a
customer we take a percentage of it it's
really simple right uh so
let's look at number 12 on our checklist
is um
focus
you need to focus on a single business
model so ask yourself in this question
are you focused on a single business
model that would be how i would uh frame
this question are you focused on a
single business now now why is that
important well it's very hard to build a
product and to find customers for it
and then it's hard to get them to pay
right but then to have multiple
different revenue streams when you're
starting out means you're taking your
team and cutting it in half so we
typically see this when somebody says
i'm going to build an advertising based
business they don't hit critical mass
then they try to turn on uh their sales
team their sales team is selling but the
advertisers say oh it's not enough you
don't have enough reach so why would i
buy an ad buy i want to spend 25k the
most you can take for me is two thousand
dollars i'm gonna go just spend my money
on reddit or twitter or facebook or
google right so
getting bogged down in multiple revenue
streams in that example the advertising
people might say okay now we're gonna
charge a subscription so now you have
people trying to sell a subscription
while another half of the is trying to
sell advertising
one side of the company is trying to
restrict access to your content in order
to get people to pay for it and the
other side is trying to sell and we saw
this at the new york times right they
were an advertising based business they
were trying to get more and more people
to the site it wasn't working they were
losing the battle at the washington post
the new york times and every other
newspaper to facebook and google which
had much
wider reach and much more data on each
individual user so what did they do
washington posted new york times they
didn't throw away their uh advertising
business they still have a vibrant
advertising business but they said you
know what
the number one business is going to be
subscription let's make that the
majority of revenue and they just turned
around those giant aircraft carriers and
you know
got them to face in another direction
and go in a different direction which
was subscriptions really hard to do
really hard to do
listen right now linkedin is going to
give you a hundred dollar credit towards
your first ad campaign that's a hyundy
for you to get new customers to run some
ads just go to linkedin.com
checklist linkedin.com
checklist and get a hundred dollar
credit right now now let's look at your
startup let's pretend you're about to
launch a campaign it tested well your
entire team is happy the creative's
great it's going according to plan but
you have this thought in the back of
your head and you should have this
thought for a reason how do i ensure the
people i want to target will be in the
mindset to receive my message while the
answer is linkedin why because when you
market on linkedin your message reaches
people who are ready to do
business linkedin equals business
business equals linkedin linkedin
business business linkedin we all know
that's the case if you're there you're
doing business right and that means your
advertising campaign will work as hard
as they can as soon as you launch it
because there are over 62 million
business decision makers on linkedin
right now waiting for you that's why
over 78 percent of b2b marketers rate
linkedin as the most effective social
media platform at helping their
organization achieve specific goals so
do business where business is done and
get a hyundy 100 ad credit at this very
new domain name linkedin.com checklist
linkedin.com
check list one word terms and condition
supply because they're giving you a
handy